Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah, just today.
Today!
Huh?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for our 67th episode today!
BAU BAU!
Today, today, today, today is FUWAMOCO Morning 67.
Another day.
Another FUWAMOCO Morning all together!
Maybe this is your first time joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning.
And for your information, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday today, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us,
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, did you BAU BAU there?
I only saw a few BAU BAUs.
BAU BAU.
Unfortunately, there's been another panel sighting.
He keeps on showing up everywhere, huh?
I'm sorry, Ruffians.
Where is it this time, Pero?
Hi.
De-den.
At first, you know, I thought it was maybe just, you know, a lovely blue sky, but... Clouds.
Yeah.
There's Pero.
Yeah, he's not a cloud.
I guess he's just going on his way from place to place, huh?
You know sometimes working on a construction site, sometimes becoming a Perroccino.
Right, yeah, but, uh, I don't know.
Taking a good look at it, he actually looks kind of nice up in the beautiful sky like that.
Kinda cute, I think.
I don't know, maybe it's the clouds.
I mean, it does make him look kind of pleasant.
No, it's super nasty!
Why?
What do you think, Ruffians?
He's living the life!
I don't know about that.
Like a cloud.
Still nasty!
His wings work.
They work.
Yeah.
Very muscular cloud.
Is Pero a relative Totoro?
No.
No, unfortunately no.
That would have been nice, but no.
Still nasty?
The verdict is in.
Still nasty.
Ruffians, you know it.
Just for your sake.
It's probably best not to make eye contact with him if you see him around, okay?
Turn around.
Like you saw an anomaly, okay?
Turn around, go the other way.
You never know what could happen.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
Yesterday was a very busy day for FUWAMOCO.
And maybe Ruffians, it was a busy day for you too.
So, we thought we'd give you an update!
Nerissa!
Advent.
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians, are you familiar with the song?
Yeah.
You know, it's a really famous winter song in Japan, you know?
It's very emotional.
It's one of the famous classic winter love songs.
You've heard it before!
It's sort of like white love!
Yeah.
But Nerissa, she sang...
A really beautiful rendition of this song, so definitely have to make sure you check it out, okay?
Ruffians!
And also take a weight off if you haven't yet either, okay?
Also a very famous winter song.
This is little time for that.
Why not?
It's our show.
Thank you for the beautiful music Nerissa!
That's what you wanted to say, huh?
That's what I wanted to say!
BAU BAU!
Something went very wrong there, huh?
Mococo.exe is still loading okay.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, today is Friday, the 67th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning, but more importantly, today is Pekora-senpai's birthday!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Happy birthday, Pekora-senpai!
Well, it's Pekora-senpai's birthday, so we phoned into her birthday stream earlier today, and somehow, there,
It was determined that we are now three sisters.
A trio of three sisters!
FUWAMOCO Pickle!
Yeah.
Got that, ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Pickle!
Yeah.
Even tail.
Check.
Silly.
Check!
Dog.
Meow.
Yeah!
You know, I don't know if this makes us triplets, like Pekora-senpai was saying earlier.
Especially since you know her birthday is today.
But... That's okay!
I know she was also saying we'd be like, soberish.
But... What about Pero?
Is he being replaced by... Peko?
I saw a ruffian asking what happened to Pororo onee-chan.
Oh, nothing.
Nothing.
We can have multiple sisters, right?
I mean, you're here too.
You're not gonna forget about me, Moco-chan.
Not like you did with Poruru-oneechan.
I did!
Wow!
Okay.
Moco-chan also drew a special picture for Pororo-san.
Yeah!
What do you think, Ruffians?
Do you like it?
Kusa.
I do it, you know.
I drew it, you know.
It's cute, it's very cute!
Do you like Pegura-senpai's teeth?
I made it accurate.
Yeah, well, Pekora-senpai, she liked it so much that she actually covered up Hakurei-senpai's picture with it.
Sorry Hakurei-senpai!
But you know, even if the ruffians think kusai, at least Pekora-senpai liked it.
That's what matters because it's for Pekora-senpai, not the ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU!
Well, ruffians.
Actually, recently, some things kind of come to our attention.
I kind of feel that ruffians, you might have noticed it too.
Maybe.
Wow, it seems like Icomochi-mama has come down with a very severe case of BAU BAU BYOU.
Did you notice it too?
Busted!
Yeah!
Yeah, well, recently Icomochi-mama has been extra sweet, and silly, and tweeting a bunch, and watching us tweet!
It makes us super duper happy!
We can't help it, you know, when we have such a wonderful, loving, and involved mama!
It makes us really happy!
You know, a mama that loves us and really wants to get to know us too!
Like Fuwawa said, very, very happy.
But, well, you know, BAU BAU will be... There's not too much known about it still.
So, we hope that Icomochi-mama's BAU BAU doesn't get too bad.
But recently, Icomochi-mama has also been tweeting lots on her sub account.
Sub account.
More than a mama!
Somehow Icomochi-mama started to feel like she's a grandpa watching over grandkids.
Makes you a ruffian, makes you watch over Icomochi-mama so her BAU BAU doesn't get
Okay, no progressing.
You know, we would definitely, definitely, definitely never, ever, ever want that, you know?
No progressing on the BAU BAU of you and me.
No.
Definitely, definitely, definitely, definitely not.
Love you Icomochi-mama!
Love you!
See you very soon.
Bye-bye!
That wouldn't be you!
But you are mama.
I don't think you're Icomochi-mama, no!
I'm not really sort of happy.
Sort of happy.
Something else.
Well, ruffians.
We know our eyes are strong, right?
Right?
We know who we are.
She even has four eyes now, right?
BAU BAU.
So then, do you know what I'm about to say, ruffians?
You know it?
You don't know it, do you, huh?
What's with that tone, Moco-chan?
I saw it.
On Twitter.
Why did you think I wouldn't say hi?
Hi!
You know, for the good ruffians who don't know what I'm talking about.
You know, on Twitter, there was some intense discussion about my fuzziness.
But,
Rather than discussion, really.
It was just bullying!
All bullying!
Saying that I should have been more curvy in some areas because this and that and this and that!
And everyone was just saying that I was pitiful!
Well, you know, there were some things like... Oh no!
Poor BAU BAU!
And...
Like, show her this and, uh, are you sure they're twins and, uh, does she lack nutrition?
Does she make it up for it in personality?
Yeah.
That I'm good despite it anyways.
Have you ever tried saying that to a girl?
Hi!
Not well.
You still like her, but despite how she looks, huh?
Huh?
What the heck?
You know what I want to say, you know?
And, you know, you wonder why I always want to be reassured, huh?
Nevermind them.
I guess.
Whatever.
Next corner!
It's okay, it's just a misunderstanding, right Ruffians?
It's just a misunderstanding, huh?
Right?
Speaking of misunderstandings, ruffians!
This is a little silly, but it seems like ever since it became the new year, there has been a serious, serious... There's been no misunderstanding.
No.
Huh?
It's good.
That's great!
For all the ruffians you know, all the ruffians out there who have interesting tastes and maybe enjoy things like the misunderstandings that were happening.
Sorry?
Not sorry.
Wow!
You know, FUWAMOCO.
Maybe we're just getting too fast to react and setting the record straight.
You know, maybe this is the power of being a member of hololive for about six months now.
What do you think?
It can't be!
No!
Can't be!
Good!
BAU BAU!
What?
I had a bunch of dreams yesterday!
It was a bit questionable though.
So, get ready, okay?
Get ready?
Explain first.
I first had a bad dream where I kind of woke up in a panic because Moco-chan died in it.
So naturally, Moco-chan let me into her bed until I calmed down.
Yeah, because I'm good.
I'm a nice little sister, okay?
Yeah, you know.
And then, well, I got maybe a bit too comfy.
She said just a bit.
And I fell asleep there.
Yeah, which led me to my next stream!
I joked that, you know, we were just about to finish the stream together with you, Ruffians!
But we were both so exhausted afterwards that I fell asleep before we ended things off.
And we just continued sleeping for 8 hours while still alive!
Eight hours.
Endurance sleep.
Endurance sleep!
Hi!
You could hear our heavy breathing and our sleep breathing really clearly!
And it was embarrassing because you could also hear our grumbly tummies too.
We didn't eat dinner yesterday so it's grumbly time.
You know, and sometimes I like roll over and we grumble and fight over the blankets!
And I start to sleep talk too.
BAU BAU.
I was really worried about it though, but when I woke up in my dream, apparently you really enjoyed it, Ruffians!
What?!
That would be a really cool stream!
Next stream of the year!
Huh?!
No way.
I woke up in a dream and I was like, oh no.
When I actually woke up I was like, oh my goodness.
Great stream idea!
New stream idea!
I thought we would though.
I don't want the ruffians to hear my grumbly tummy.
I guess you like that sort of idea high.
Hi!
I don't know, ruffians!
Please!
BAU BAU!
You have a weird high.
Fuwawa is weird for having a weird dream!
And the ruffians are weird for liking it.
And weird for bullying me.
Ruffians completely forgot about my bad dream though, huh?
They didn't care enough.
Why do you like Doggie of the Day?
Yo, let's check out who is the Doggie of the Day today.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Kii!
Hi Kii!
Kii is so handsome!
I feel like we've had a lot of huskies, huh?
Oh, well, the more huskies...
I guess it is snowy.
Right!
Yeah, well, King is apparently a very silly rascal.
I just love him very, very dearly.
Yeah, he has a little hard time hearing, but that doesn't stop him at all!
Actually, I... Last night, cause, you know, we had to record.
Fuwawa was having issues.
Whenever I went, BAU BAU!
At a certain frequency, you're here with me like, I can't tell what's going on.
Yeah, it was just funny.
It's so cute though.
How in this game BAU BAU?
I think, I think it's, huh?
BAU BAU!
That intense?
Yeah, very loud.
Like BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
No, like that.
It could be that.
Like that?
Strong BAU BAU!
That's pretty good.
Like that?
I don't think that came BAU BAUs like that though.
Then which is it?
I think it's more like yours.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, Kate, Kate is loving life together with you.
He's ready for all the days, you know, spring, summer, fall, and especially the snowy winter ones.
He's ready to have a lot of fun together with his dear ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Now, next for today, I went on a walk
We have... De-den!
Is this a walk?
It's a massive moth!
A massive walk!
A massive walk on a massive moth?
Or a massive walk on a massive moth?
Which one is it?
We both think moths are really cool, but... Yeah.
To be honest, I think I'd probably scream if I saw this one flying around.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, you too?
If it's just a word, it's not that bad.
It's like a bird.
It's very pretty.
It also looks like it has snake heads on it.
I'm not a fan of that.
Well, Moc-sister!
We hope you had a wonderful time visiting your grandparents!
We're sure you brought a big smile to their faces.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our question of the day.
It is de-den!
In what ways do you feel you've changed the most since your debut?
It's surely been a big lifestyle switch since your time in the show, so how do you think that has affected you the most?
Ah, lifestyle switch.
Ruffians!
You know how hungry we were when we debuted and everything.
Pretty hungry, right?
No, I think we were able to show that with our actions too.
Hungry.
You know, today!
Today even marks our 250th video actually!
If this happens.
But to tell you the truth, Ruffians... Well...
You've made us even hungrier now.
Oops!
So we want to keep aiming as high as we can.
You know, pushing through the tough times so that we can make some amazing things happen all together.
So you know, we're just continuing to run just as fast as we have since we debuted back in July.
And hopefully all of our crazy dreams can come true, okay?
But, you know, at the end of the day, we're just FUWAMOCO.
So we're gonna have fun with it.
Yeah, have fun.
Do our best.
Let's see what happens.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for all your submissions!
Please remember that FUWAMOCO Morning is something we make together.
So, we're always waiting for more of your questions!
Your Doggy of the Days, your Pero Sightings, your vlogs!
All your submissions, okay?
And FUWAMOCO Scoop, don't forget!
Ruffians, I know you can.
You know what's going on.
You are good at journalism.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
We can still be good employees.
Great assets.
BAU BAU!
And we take a peek at the schedule.
The schedule.
Well, on Saturday we have a rock n' roll party!
Rock n' roll party!
I'm a ruffian as well.
This time, there's a theme.
There's usually a theme.
A theme that we're very excited about.
Yeah.
Right.
Tell us.
It's not Apple.
De-den!
The theme is winter songs!
BAU BAU!
We're really excited to be singing some of our favorite winter anime songs and G-POP.
Got some extra special songs prepared for you too, so please don't miss it, okay?
Prepared specially for this, okay?
Snow Halation?
What do you mean?
I've never ever heard of that song.
Ever.
That's the song you sing in the summertime, right?
Definitely.
Yeah.
Well, it's also not on our schedule, but...
On Sunday, we'll also be continuing to read your superchats before I go home.
I'm from 1pm PT, right?
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for being so patient with us.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And just like that, another week comes to an end.
But!
Now we're just ahead of a very fun weekend coming up.
We hope you're looking forward to it!
Remember ruffians, no bullying!
Yeah.
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special ruffians today!
First time ruffian!
BAU BAU!
TaroTaro!
Corgis9!
BAU BAU!
RuffianLux!
Everyone!
BAU BAU!
Buppe.
Demi Itami.
BAU BAU!
Zelfie.
Mango Donut.
BAU BAU!
Micmac.
Mellow Ruffian.
BAU BAU!
Misty.
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!